millions of people around the world
today are gathering for climate strikes
they want their governments to take more
action on climate protection ahead of a
key UN summit that's coming up next week
now Australia hosting some of today's
first mass rallies with similar protests
expected to unfold across some 150
countries in the hours ahead the
demonstrations are being held with
activist Greta turn bergs Friday for
future movement which invites young
people to stage school strikes for the
climate they don't have to well I say in
school I'm learning about the effects of
climate change and I'm learning that we
need to do something
yet I'm seeing that the people in charge
and the people who are running our
country aren't doing anything to me this
is confusing so I'm here today to step
up and say no more well throughout the
day we'll be checking in with our
correspondents reporting from the
climate protests all around the world
let's go first to the Philippines
capital a to Manila where DWS Anna
Santos is standing by for us Anna good
day to you can you tell us what's
happening where you are I'm here at the
University of the Philippines where
students have gathered they've skipped
classes to join this protest for climate
justice they're joined by members of
indigenous communities who have been
displaced from their homes because of
severe weather conditions and other
environmental degradation now see behind
me the protest it's really like play for
their cartoon characters or people on
stilts but the students are very clear
make no mistake they are very serious
about demanding climate justice and the
serious response from the government
they want the government to declare a
climate emergency here in the
Philippines
okay now the Philippines are of course
at a special risk of a climate change
with an global warming with so many
islands and archipelagos what challenges
is the Philippines phaser
the Philippines is listed as the third
most climate vulnerable country in the
world and the first to feel the effects
of climate change are really the people
at the peripherals of society these are
the ones we live in the coastal areas
are fishermen the ones who are farming
and also those who live in urban poor or
marginalized communities the ones who
are in very vulnerable housing they feel
the effects immediately now these people
are here at this protest and they're
joined by the students who are saying
that they are also feeling the effects
of climate change because they fear for
their future they are disappointed that
the government is not sending a
representative to the COP talks this
December the president said that the
talks will call for emission our decline
in carbon emissions and that
disproportionately affects countries
like the Philippines who don't really
contribute to carbon emissions but the
youth are saying that's precisely where
our voices need to be heard that's
precisely where the Philippines a very
vulnerable country needs to stay that we
want our homes to be protected we want a
future okay and thank you very much for
that from Manila ana santos for us at
the protests in Manoa
well DWS Phoebe Kong is in the Taiwanese
capital Taipei she gave us this
assessment of what's happening there
today well now in downtown Taipei where
there is a group of students from
universities high schools and even
primary schools they are now holding a
press conference right here right behind
me and thousands of the students they
attend and participate in this press
conference during school time today and
the Reta our youth climate change
declarations which is to address the
climate change problems around the world
and they want to urge the politicians
especially the presidential elections
candidates to address this problem that
is to put this issue and put it to the
mutual agenda and platforms that is to
occur the greenhouse gases and and also
to control the temperature rise under
the 2015
Paris climate agreement so that is that
goal and this is the first activities to
check after one week long movement in
Taiwan so there will be a series of
protests and also street talks to
address the climate change problems on
the coming few days
well the initiator of the Friday's for
future strikes credit tune burgers to
spearhead a rally later today in New
York last month she traveled to the US
to be on hand for next week's climate
summit at the UN it was her appeals that
have mobilized so many young people
scientists environmental organizations
and politicians have been trying for
years to make the climate a matter of
urgency in vain Cikini old Vita two Moog
has done it turn Berg braved the open
sea on a two-week voyage aboard a yacht
from Europe to the US to bring her
message to the American president a
self-proclaimed climate skeptic in
person the media followed the trip
closely the climate and ecological
crisis is a global crisis and the
biggest crisis humanity has ever faced
and if we don't manage to work together
to cooperate and to to work together
despite our differences then we will
fail so we need to to stand together and
support each other and and to take
action it all started about a year ago
every Friday glutted windbag protested
in front of the Swedish parliament and
in so doing sparked the Friday's for
future movement just a few months later
the school girl mobilized millions of
people for the climate
suddenly young people all over the world
took to the streets like here in India
in Mexico or in Australia
or in Europe
[Applause]
after her arrival in New York at the end
of August to an bag made it clear at a
meeting with UN General Assembly
President Malia Espinosa
that she hoped the upcoming climate
Gathering would lead to concrete actions
to be some kind of breaking point where
people start to realize what is actually
going on and so we have high
expectations in YouTube and all Member
States to to deliver now tune Berg is
counting on the support of her fellow
campaigners all over the world and one
of those fellow campaigners is now with
us here in the studio
Clara Mayer of Friday's for future
supporter here in Berlin good morning
Clara good morning what do you want to
see come out of today's protests around
the world I hope that the world
politicians recognize us and that they
actually start acting that the UN
climate summit will come up with a real
solution against this crisis because
this crisis will affect every single one
of us okay now a lot of schools here in
Germany are giving students the day off
without penalty to take part in these
strikes why do you think this movement
has become so very strong here in
Germany well we've seen a lot of
stagnation the politics in Germany we've
had the same Chancellor for a long time
and she hasn't done much we are a
country with a lot of resources we are a
very wealthy country we have the
opportunities to become a leader against
the fight in the fight against climate
change but we are not and that is a
scandal and I think that's why people
are so frustrated especially in Germany
that the government isn't doing anything
although they have the capacity to so
okay you saw us talking to Taipei Taiwan
there and you saw the the young people
there there they're not as engaged as we
could see there is as we heard is the
young people here in Germany especially
if you look at the numbers out on the
streets every Friday here in Germany
what would you say to young people in
Taipei to Taiwan um I would say to them
that this is an issue that will affect
everyone on this planet and that I hope
that even though
they might not be striking today I hope
that they will in the future because
this issue will really affect every
single citizen on this planet okay as
part of that more and more students are
taking part in in the strike you know
there have been families fined for
allowing their children to go to to the
strikes and their sanctions threatened
for families in the future should their
children do do so the argument there is
that children should be learning and not
protesting out on a school day what's
your response to that I know people who
have been fined and I think it's
actually like a scandal because we
learned so much from the strikes this is
not about algebra this is about learning
about real Paul like world politics
every single one of us has learned so
much while striking this is about our
future our planet our lives and to
restrict people fighting for this cause
is a scandal in my opinion okay talking
about politics the German government is
looking to introduce a number of
measures to to reduce carbon emissions
here in Germany let's take a look at
that and talk to more than Germans love
to cycle they diligently recycle when it
comes to the environment Germans like to
consider themselves model citizens even
Angela Merkel was once hailed as the
climate Chancellor for pushing other
countries to acknowledge the scale of
climate change
Merkel's government also decided to
phase out nuclear energy by 2022 but
still Germany is no climate change role
model in fact it is one of the countries
with the highest co2 emissions worldwide
Germany wants to have these emissions by
2030 experts warn it won't meet this
target why it's early exit from nuclear
energy made Germany heavily reliant on
fossil fuels manufacturing transport and
other industries also contribute to
Germany's high emissions
how can Germany reduce its greenhouse
gases a minimum price for budget
airlines is under consideration other
ideas include improving public transport
to encourage people to use their cars
less the biggest thing Germany can do is
reduce its fossil fuel consumption
Germany only wants to phase out coal
energy by 2038
in the meantime it wants to tax carbon
dioxide a carbon tax would make coal and
other fossil fuels more expensive but
the proposals targeting fossil fuels
have been met with resistance coal
miners and other industrial workers fear
for their jobs climate activists have
taken to the streets hoping to persuade
the German government to take action now
okay Clara these actions that the German
governments looking at could mean higher
taxes the loss of jobs is it worth it
climate action - when you look at that
well I think that's always a false way
to look at it last year we lost 3,000
jobs in renewable energies the that is
not even equal to the slight amount of
jobs we would lose in coal and also
there studies that the coal miners can
actually work in other parts of another
businesses but this is about a real
issue that will affect every single
person on this planet we had time to
solve this issue and make it a win-win
issue for everyone but the government
has been sleeping for years and now we
just have to realize that this is an
issue where we have to do every single
measure we can and of course climate
justice is a really important factor for
us so we want no one left behind you
want to tax the rich the people that are
flying the most the people that have the
biggest cars have the biggest houses
that emit the most and those are not the
working people okay you call it you're
calling a climate justice briefly if you
could do you think the politicians are
listening and if they're not will they
be listening after today I definitely
think they will after today I mean we'll
have millions of people all across the
world on the streets if they will not be
listening well they're fools sorrow
thank you very much for coming in today
Clara Maya from the Fridays for future
here in Berlin thanks very much Claire